[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH D'ANGELO: Welcome.
So today, we're here to talk to
you about dead easy Kubernetes
workflows with
Visual Studio Code.
And to get us started,
we're going to tell you
a little bit about ourselves.
So hi, everyone.
I'm Sarah.
I'm a user experience researcher
on Google Cloud Platform.
And I do research to understand
and improve developer
experience with our tools.
So it's my job to
talk to all of you,
and listen to your
needs and pain points,
and make sure we address
those with our tools.
And this is my dog, Smokey,
who I love very much.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY:
Hello, everyone.
This is Sujit.
I'm a software engineer
on the Cloud Code team.
I work on tools that
improve developer experience
with Kubernetes.
And this is my
cricket bat, which
is pretty excited that, after a
long winter, summer is coming.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So how
many people in the audience
are developing
Kubernetes applications
or planning to in the future?
Awesome.
That's a lot of you.
We're really excited
that you're here.
I've talked to a lot of
you about your experience
with Kubernetes.
And one thing that I've heard
is that it can be frustrating.
And you said things like,
there's too much configuration.
Debugging is a pain.
Applications have so
many moving parts,
and you're just spending way too
much time outside of your code.
So let's break this
down a little bit.
Why is Kubernetes difficult?
Well, in my
conversations with you,
I've heard a few
things like this.
Getting started is
hard, because it
can be a big conceptual shift.
And getting a hello world
application up and running just
takes way too much time.
And once you have
hello world ready go,
the complexity of
Kubernetes really
kicks in, because
developers have
to learn a lot of new
things, like containers,
Y syntax, and Kubernetes
client tools, like kubectl.
And then when you're
ready to deploy,
there's a lot of moving parts.
You have to build, tag, and push
your images to your repository
and manage clusters.
And then if something goes
wrong, which typically happens,
troubleshooting
can be a huge pain.
Because setting up debugging
is difficult, and identifying
the cause of your
problems is hard.
And so we want to help
you with each of these.
And Sujit is here to tell
us a little bit about how.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY:
Thank you, Sarah.
So let me now
introduce Cloud Code.
Cloud Code is a set of
integrated tools from Google
that let you focus
more on your code,
worrying less about the
tool chain, configuration,
and management of your app.
Over the past several
months, we have
been working super-hard to help
solve some of the pain points
Sarah has described.
And we are very excited
to launch the Cloud Code
extension for Visual Studio
Code, which is currently
in beta.
So what do we have
in this extension?
This extension provides a simple
getting started experience
for user new to
Kubernetes, helps
with the local
application development,
streamlines the
deployment process,
and help you troubleshoot your
applications through debugging
and logs.
In today's talk, we
are going to demo
all of these and some more.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So
that's a lot to cover,
and we should get started.
And I want to say, just
as Sujit mentioned,
we're going to be covering
the end-to-end developer
workflow with Kubernetes.
So there's going to
be a lot of code,
but also a lot of
really cool features
that we're excited to show you.
So let's jump over to
Visual Studio Code.
How many Visual
Studio Code users
do we have in the
audience today?
Awesome.
We're really excited
that you're all here
and that we get to
show you Cloud Code.
So here, I've got
Visual Studio Code open,
and I've got Cloud
Code installed.
So I'm going to get us started
on the welcome page, which
is going to have a
lot of good resources
when you're just
starting with Cloud Code.
What you'll see first
off is that we've got
support for four languages--
Go, Node, Java, and Python.
You're going to find information
about the prerequisites
to have installed
when using Cloud Code.
And for context, what I
have on this machine here
is Docker desktop with
Kubernetes enabled
and Scaffold.
And like I said, we really
care about your feedback,
and we want to make sure
that we're creating tools
to meet your needs.
So we've got sections over
here in the Resources tab
for you to file an issue
and request a feature.
We really hope you use
this, because Sujit, I,
and the rest of our
team are constantly
checking what you'd like
to see in Cloud Code,
so we can make improvements.
And so now, let's get started
with our first hello world app.
As you can see here, I
could get started right
from the Resources tab, or
I can use a command pallet--
Command Shift P. I'm going
to search for Cloud Code.
And what you'll see
right off the bat
is a lot of contributions
that we've made.
We're not going to have time
to go through all these today,
but there's so much for you
to explore after our talk.
I'm going to use the Cloud Code
command for new application.
And here, you'll see the
support for those languages
that I mentioned and a
couple of templates that you
can use to get started.
I'm going to select the
Python hello world template.
It's going to ask me
where I want to save that.
And now, it's going to
populate a new hello world
template for me.
Sujit, can you tell
me a little bit
about what this template has?
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Sure.
So all the applications
that I've created
is in the Cloud
Code new application
command are deploy-ready
and debug-ready.
So in this case, we have a
simple hello application,
with a single
microservice in it.
All the source code
of the microservice
can be found in the
source folder here, along
with the Docker file that
containerizes the microservice.
We also have all the
Kubernetes resources
of this application in the
Kubernetes Manifest folder.
And we also have
launched our JSON file
that contains the necessary
debug configuration
of this application.
And finally, we have the
Scaffold [INAUDIBLE] here.
So Cloud Code leverages an open
source tool, called Scaffold,
that helps us with
building and deploying
Kubernetes applications.
This Scaffold
configuration file here
contains one or more
deployment profiles
that defines how the application
should be built and deployed.
I would like to add
one more thing here.
The templates we
have seen just before
are coming from external
public repositories.
This helps scale the templates,
independent of the extension,
so in time, you can expect
to find a lot more useful
templates in this area.
SARAH D'ANGELO:
That's really awesome,
because providing more
templates for developers
is going to help them expand
their Kubernetes applications
quickly and easily.
So let's go ahead and deploy
this Kubernetes application.
I'm going to go back
to the command pallet.
And I'm going to use
the command for deploy,
and then I'm going to select
the default profile, which
came with my template.
And then it's going to ask
me where I want to deploy to.
And like I said, I
already have Docker
for desktop on this machine,
with Kubernetes enabled.
But we do also have
support from Minikube.
So here we go.
We've kicked off our deployment,
and we have it all ready to go.
And there we go.
I just applied my first
hello world application,
and I didn't have
to write any code.
So let's take a
minute to summarize
what we've shown you so far.
We just showed
you how easy it is
to get started with our
templates in Cloud Code
and how quickly you
can deploy locally.
But let's really get into it.
Sujit and I have a
question we'd really
like to ask you at
the end of the talk.
So we're going to build
a voting application
from scratch using Cloud Code.
Sujit, take it away.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Let's
build a voting application
from scratch using the
Cloud Code extension.
The goal for the
rest of the talk
is to build an iterative
application locally.
And when it's ready, we'll
deploy it to remote cluster,
so we all can access
this application.
The application
itself is very simple.
It has just two microservices--
a front end and a back end
call voting service.
Even though we'll
be using node.js
for both of these
microservices, everything
we are going to show in this
demo is language agnostic.
The front end has two
HTML pages-- an index page
that lets us post the
work and a results page,
where we can see all
the voting results.
And similarly,
the voting service
has two HTP endpoints,
a GET endpoint
that returns all
the votes posted
so far and a post-end point that
it takes and saves a new vote.
So now, you go ahead and show
how this final application
going to look like.
So you'll have a
frame of reference
of what we are trying to build.
I'll go to cloudcodeexample.com.
And now, we are seeing the
index page of the front end.
And we can submit a
vote and as we can see,
a post ingress has been
made to the slash vote
URL, which is being sold
by the voting service.
And similarly, when we
navigate to the Results page,
we can see that
a GET request has
been made to the slash
vote URL, which is being
solved by the voting service.
And it didn't solve the votes
that were posted so far.
And these votes are being
displayed in the space here,
so real simple.
So now, I'll go back to the ID.
And we'll close the
hello world application,
and I will open a new
directory called voting
app, which is currently empty.
[INAUDIBLE] or
the source folder,
which is where we'll
keep the source code
for all of our microservices.
I'll get a terminal,
and I will use
GET clone to fetch the source
code for the front end service.
And we'll do the same
for the voting service.
The source code for these
microservices is real simple.
So the front end service
has an extra js file.
We just configure it to
[INAUDIBLE] static HTML content
from public directory.
And the public directory has
the HTML pages we saw before.
And similarly,
the voting service
has indexed our js
file, and it has
the implementation for
the HTTP GET endpoint
and the implementation for
the HTTP post endpoint.
The votes posted will be stored
locally on the machine using
an MP module.
And both of these microservices
have Docker files with them.
And now, in order to deploy
this application to a Kubernetes
cluster, we need to have
the corresponding Kubernetes
resources.
I'll switch back to the slides.
And these how our Kubernetes
resources going to look
like in our cluster.
For each of the
microservices, we'll
have a deployment and a
service resource that helps us
with deploying and
exposing this microservice
within the cluster.
We'll also have an
ingress resource,
which helps us in rerouting
the external traffic coming
to the cluster to
these microservices.
So all the traffic
coming to the route URL
will be redirected to
the front end service.
And all the traffic coming
to the slash vote URL
will be redirected to
the voting service.
So now, let's add this
file Kubernetes resources
to our application.
Is there anything
more [INAUDIBLE]
than writing YAML on
a beautiful sunny day?
Isn't it, Sarah?
Isn't it what our
customers are telling us?
SARAH D'ANGELO: No,
not at all, Sujit.
How many of you in the audience
enjoy writing and editing
YAML files?
[AUDIENCE MEMBERS WHOOPS]
All right, you got a couple of
friends, but I'm going to say,
the majority do not.
And so this is a
great opportunity
to show how easy it is to
write YAML using Cloud Code.
Because developers are
always saying that writing
YAML can be error-prone both
syntactically and semantically.
And we've got some really
cool resources for you
that Sujit's going to show us.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Let's do this.
And no GET clone this time.
So we'll start by creating a
new folder called Kubernetes
manifest, which is where
we'll keep all the Kubernetes
resources of this application.
And let's go ahead and
create frontend.yaml file
to add the deployment
of the service resources
for the front end.
The fastest way to add
a Kubernetes resources
is throw out snippets.
So I'll go ahead and
press Control-Space here.
And we can see a list of
snippets available for us.
I'll go ahead and use the
Kubernetes deployments snippet.
And now, we have a basic
deployment resource added.
Let's change the names.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And I'll press the Tab, and
I'll change that image name
to front end image.
And we'll do one more Tab.
And let's leave the
container port as is.
As you can see, adding
a Kubernetes resource
through snippets
is extremely easy.
And typically, after
adding new resource,
you may want to understand
certain properties on them.
For example, I may
want to understand
what this particular
resource does here.
For that, I can simply
hover over those properties,
and we can get a
brief description
of what the properties, along
with the link to the official
Kubernetes documentation.
So next, we'll add
a service resource.
We'll again use the snippets.
We'll use the Kubernetes
service snippet.
And let's change the name.
And for a service to
work with ingress,
the type of the service has
to be either node port or node
balancer.
So I'll use node port here.
And plus tab, let's
use the port as 4001.
I will leave the
target port as is,
because it has to match with
the container port here.
So far, we have added both
the deployment and the service
resources that are needed
for the front end service.
So typically, after
running new resources,
you may want to fine tune
them by adding or removing
certain properties.
So in order to add
new properties,
you can simply go to a
specific location and press
Control-Space.
And you'll see a list
of possible suggestions
available at that
particular location.
So we can go ahead and use
external traffic policy here
and press Control-Space again.
Now, we can see a list
of possible values
for that particular property.
We also have a brief
description of that property
on the right-hand side,
which will come in handy
when you want to decide
which of these properties
you would like to use.
But for this demo, we
won't need this property,
so we'll not have it.
So next, we'll try to quickly
add what the deployment
and the service resources
for the voting service.
We'll go create a new
file called voting.yaml
And we'll leave the
container port as is.
And then we'll add
the service to source.
Oops, looks like
there is a typo.
And as you can see, we also
have a nice validation support
available as well.
Let's fix that.
And now, we have added four
out of the five Kubernetes
resources that we need
for this application.
Let's add the last one.
We'll create the ingress.yaml
to add the ingress resource.
Ingress resource helps us
redirect the traffic coming
to the cluster to the services
in the application based
on the host name,
URL path, et cetera.
So in our application, we have
two services-- the front end
service and the voting service.
And let's reroute the traffic
coming to the route URL
to the front end service.
For that, I'll go to the service
name and press Control-Space
to get a list of
available suggestions
for the service names.
Some of these suggestions are
coming from the Kubernetes
manifest in the
application directly,
as denoted by the local suffix.
And some of the
other suggestions,
like Kubernetes
and Python, hello
world external are coming from
the current active cluster
configured on my machine.
So I'll go ahead and use
the front-end service.
And now, we need to know the
service port of the front end.
You guys may have noticed,
the front-end service here
is clickable so I can simply
hold on the front-end service
and use command click, or
I can right click and use
the Go to Definition option.
And now, it takes us
directly to the definition
of the Kubernetes resource.
I'll copy the port number, and
we'll use it in the ingress.
Next, let's try to redirect the
traffic coming into the slash
vote URL to the voting service.
For that, we'll add
another entry here--
view slash vote.
And now, I'll lose
Control-Space once again
and use the voting service.
And now, we need we need to know
the port of the voting service.
For that we'll right click
on the voting service
and use the Peek
Definition option here.
And now, the definition
of the voting service
is displayed right
here in this file.
These features
come in real handy,
especially when I have large
number of Kubernetes resources
in our application.
We also have the same tool tips
support available in this mode.
We copy the port
number, and close this,
and we'll use it here.
And that's it.
We have added all the
Kubernetes resources
that we need for
this application.
But before we move on, I'll
add a couple of annotations
in order to use a non-default
ingress controller
and to stop SSL redirection.
SARAH D'ANGELO:
Sujit, I just want
to take a minute to say that
you wrote a ton of YAML,
and you made that
look super-easy.
Those resources,
like those snippets,
auto-complete, go-to
definitions are
going to be super-helpful
for developers
who are new to Kubernetes
and those who've
been using it for a long time.
So it's really great
to see those features.
So to summarize, we've
seen a lot of code.
And what Sujit has done so
far is gotten the source code
for our microservices and
Docker file, and then added
all the Kubernetes
resources we need
to deploy this application.
So what's next?
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Next, we'll
try to deploy this application
to the local cluster.
So for that, I'll go
to the command pallet
and use Cloud Code deploy.
And because there are
no deployment profiles
created in this
application so far,
it's prompting us to create one.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So
wait a second, Sujit.
Can you tell us a
little bit about what
deployment profiles do for us?
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Sure.
In the real world, an
application typically
results in multiple
environments,
such as dev, test,
staging, prod, et cetera.
You may want to build and deploy
your application differently
based on the environment.
For example, in dev
environment, you
may want to use Docker CLI to
build your application and use
kubectl to deploy
the application
to your local cluster, such as
Minikube or Docker for desktop.
And in staging
environment, you may
want to use Google
Cloud Build to build you
application and use customize
to deploy the application
to a remote GKE cluster.
Deployment profiles
help us do this.
For each of the environment
you would like your application
to be supported
in, you will just
have to create a
deployment profile
and let the Cloud Code
take care of the rest.
So now, we'll go ahead and
create our first deployment
profile to work against
the local environment.
And for that, we'll
click as here.
And now, it has
analyzed the application
and prompting us to provide a
mapping between the image names
in the Kubernetes
manifest and the Docker
files in this application.
So why do we need to
provide this mapping?
Usually, in order to
deploy an application,
we'll have to build
out the Docker files
in the application, tag them,
push them to a repository,
and then update our Kubernetes
manifest with the image paths.
The deploy process is
asking for this mapping,
so it can do all of these
tasks on our behalf.
So I'll go ahead and
use the front-end Docker
file for the front-end image
and the voting service Docker
file for the voting
image and press Save.
And now, we have our first
deployment profile created.
We can also see that the
corresponding scaffold.yaml
file has been created in
the application directory.
So the default profile
here is configured
to use Docker engine APIs
to build this application.
And this behavior can be
fine-tuned with the properties
available here.
And the default
profile is configured
to use kubectl to
deploy this application.
We can add more profiles as
we need using the Add New
option here, or we can
use the Edit button here
to edit the profile.
So I'll go ahead and edit it.
Instead of hardcoding
all the five parts,
I'll use a wildcard,
so we don't have
to worry when new
files are added
or existing files are
removed from this folder.
So now, I'll proceed
with the deployment,
and we'll select the default
profile we just created.
And we'll use Docker for desktop
for the local environment.
And now, the deployment
process has started,
and we see the status of the
deployment in the status bar
here.
Currently, it's waiting for
the rollout of the front end.
And now, it's waiting for the
rollout of the voting service.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So,
Sujit, this seems
to be taking a
little bit of time.
And I can see there's some
error logs in the output window.
What's going on here?
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Looks like
there is an issue here.
So typically, after
triggering the deployment,
the Cloud Code
deploy command also
streams the logs from the
corresponding parts directly
to the output
window, which is what
seems to be happening here.
Just a second.
Yeah, it was not
visible in that mode.
So we also have a
few other options
available to diagnose
the deployment issues.
And to access them, we can
simply click on the stats bar
here.
And here, we can see
the Display Pods option
if you want to know more detail
about the current pod status.
And we have the Show
Logs option here.
But because we
already have the error
logs in the output window,
I'll go ahead and stop
waiting for the rollout.
Let's see what's going on here.
It looks like we are in
index.js js file, line 13.
We are using an await method
in a non-async function.
Let's go to the next .js file.
And looks like we are
using await incorrectly
here in a non-async function.
And because this bug is in the
start-up code of the container,
the deployment has failed.
So let's fix this and
do a deployment again.
Now, the deployment
is in progress again.
And now, the deployment
has happened successfully.
So as we can also see, all
the publicly-exposed endpoints
in the application are displayed
directly in output window.
I'll go ahead and click on
the front-end service here.
And now, we can
see the front end
of our application, which is
deployed in the Kubernetes
cluster.
So we'll submit a
vote and see if we're
able to successfully
post a vote.
Oops, looks like the request
to the voting service
has failed with an
internal server error.
There seems to a bug in
the voting service code.
And let's try to
troubleshoot this issue
by directly debugging the
application in the Kubernetes
cluster.
In order to debug a microservice
using the Cloud Code extension,
we need to do two things.
The first thing is to ensure
that the Docker file that we
are using is debug-ready.
So in the case of node.js, that
means using the inspect flag
in the start-up command.
And we have similar instructions
available for other languages
in our documentation.
And the second
thing we need to do
is to add the corresponding
debug configuration.
Currently, there are
no configurations.
We can add a configuration using
an Add Configuration option
there.
And we can select the
Cloud Code debug here.
But I will add debug confusion
a slightly different way.
I'll go to the .vscode folder
and add a new file called
launch.json.
And I'll go to the
Configurations section
here and press Control-Space.
Here, we can see a list
of Cloud Code debug
snippets available for us.
And because the voting services
is written using node.js,
we'll go ahead and use
the node.js snippet.
Here, you'll see a number of
options, but in most cases,
you'll have to worry
about just three of these.
So the first is a name.
Let's name it debug voting.
And the second one
is a local route.
This is for the debugger
to know the source code
location of your microservice.
The source code of
the voting services
is in the source folder here.
So we'll go ahead
and update that.
And the third thing
is the pod selector.
This is to uniquely identify
the microservice pod
in the cluster.
So we'll go to that
voting.yaml file
and see the ports
that we are using.
Looks like we are
using app:voting.
So let's copy this and use
it in the launch.json file.
And because we have
updated the Docker file,
let's do one more deployment.
And now, the application has
been deployed successfully.
And now, we have
everything we need
to debug this microservice.
So I'll go to the
index.js file, and we'll
set a big point in
the first method
here, and then go
to the Debug window
and press Debug Voting button.
Next, let's try to
submit the vote,
and the breakpoint has been hit.
Now, we are [INAUDIBLE]
the application deployed
in a Kubernetes cluster.
So we can see all the
properties of the request
object and the response object.
And we can step through
the code line by line.
And we also have
some debug windows
available on the left-hand side.
So we have the
call stack window,
and we have the
variables window here,
where we can watch the
block local, local,
and global variables.
And we also have the
watch window here.
We can inspect the
variable names.
Looks like the vote we have
just posted is coming out fine.
Let's see what's going on
in the vote subject here.
It looks like it's
undefined right now.
Let's step through.
Looks like we are
trying to access
a property on the vote subject
here, which is currently
undefined.
And it's failing with an
internal server error.
So let's stop debugging,
fix this issue.
We'll instantiate with an empty
object when it's undefined,
and deploy this.
Let's see if it's
working this time.
And now, we're able to
post the vote successfully.
Awesome.
So let's take a
quick summary of what
we have done in this section.
So we started with
an empty directory
and added the source code
for the microservices
along with the Docker files.
And then we added the
Kubernetes manifest that are
needed for this application.
And then we created our
first deployment profile
for our local
environment, and then we
diagnosed the deployment
issues with the help
of the logs that were streamed
directly to the output window.
And finally, we
were able to debug
an application deployed
in the Kubernetes cluster
and fix the bug.
Awesome.
So far, we are only able to see
this application on my machine
here.
Next, let's try to
deploy this application
to a remote cluster, so
you all can access it.
Sarah, [INAUDIBLE] GKE.
Would you like to show
us how to create a GKE
cluster with an IDE?
SARAH D'ANGELO:
Yeah, I'd love to.
It's great how easy
it is to create
a cluster right from within
the IDE using Cloud Code.
So I'm going to click our
Cloud Code icon over here
in the activity bar.
We're going to see
that's about to populate
all the clusters we have
available in our GKE account.
And if I to add a new
one, all I have to do
is click this Plus button.
And it's going to open the
cluster creation wizard
for me, which is going to
let me create a new cluster
from within the IDE.
And so what I can do is
set a default project IDE,
choose a zone--
whichever one I'm
feeling like today--
and customize my cluster.
So give it a name,
if I can type.
And I can do things, like
enable Istio and Cloud Run
right from in the
cluster creation wizard.
And then I can create
this cluster right here.
And I want to mention that
while we're showing you
this awesome workflow in GKE,
we do know that a lot of you
are using multiple
clouds or other clouds.
And so I want to point out that
we have the support for AWS
and Azure as well.
And so I can go ahead and click
Create Cluster and get this up
and running.
But we have limited
time for this demo.
So Sujit and I
already made a cluster
that's ready to go
for our voting demo.
I'm going to right
click here and set it
as the active cluster.
And then we're going
to see it populate over
here in our cluster
explorer, which I'll
talk about in a little bit.
But we have a few more steps
before this application
is ready to deploy to GKE.
Sujit, what do we
have to do next?
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Next, in order
to deploy this application
to the GKE cluster, you
go to the command pallet
and use Cloud Code deploy.
We won't be using
the default profile,
because it is configured to work
against the local environment.
We'll use the Add Edit
Profile option here.
And now, we are back to the
deployment profile wizard.
I'll use the Add New option
here to write a new profile.
Let's call it GKE.
And instead of inheriting the
build settings from the default
profile, we'll go
ahead and change it
to Google Cloud Build.
And now, as you can
see, the project IDE
has been auto-populated with
my default Google Cloud project
IDE.
Let's continue to inherit
the deployment settings
from the default profile,
which is currently
configured to use kubectl.
If you need more
customization options,
you can directly work with
the scaffold.yaml file here.
I'll go ahead and press Save
and proceed with the deployment.
And we'll use the GKE profile,
and we'll use the cluster
that Sarah has just started.
And now, it's prompting
us for the image registry.
Because we are deploying
this application
to a remote cluster,
we also need
to push the images to
a registry which is
accessible from that cluster.
And it's currently
auto-populated with my default
gcr.registry.
Let's go ahead and use it.
And now, the
deployment has started.
When the deployment
is in progress,
I would like to bring
to your attention
a number of things that are
happening behind the scenes.
The Cloud Code deploy command
is building all the Docker files
in the application using
Google Cloud Build,
tagging them, and pushing
them to the remote registry--
in this case, gcr.io.
And then it will update
all the Kubernetes
manifest in the application
with a new image path,
then uses kubectl to
apply the Kubernetes
manifest to the remote cluster.
After this, it will wait till
all the deployment resources
are rolled out successfully.
It then waits till
all the load balancers
and the ingress resources
in the application
are assigned an IP address.
And finally, if you pull all
the publicly-exposed endpoints
in the application, I'll
display them right here
in the output window.
Now, it's currently waiting
for the ingress resource.
Let's wait for it for
a few more seconds.
Awesome.
So now, let's use the link here.
And now, we are
browsing the application
deployed to the GKE cluster.
Let's submit a vote.
And awesome, it's working.
SARAH D'ANGELO: Great.
I'm glad we got
that all working.
And I want to take a minute
to go back to the IDE
and show you all one
of my favorite features
of Cloud Code, which
is cluster explorer.
This is really great,
because it provides
a lot of visibility into
your Kubernetes clusters,
which is something that
I hear from developers
is a really useful
feature of Cloud Code.
And so some things
you can do here
are see a lot of your Kubernetes
resources right from the IDE.
And you can perform simple
actions against those
and use them to find
out more information
about what's going on.
So if we want to check out
how our deployments are doing,
you can open Deployments tab.
And we'll see both
our deployments
are running as expected as
indicated by the screen icon
here.
If something wasn't going
right, that would be yellow.
We can look inside
of our deployments
to see the replicas.
And if we want to scale,
those will update.
And if we want any
more information,
we can right click to
describe our deployment.
And so we'll get all that
information here as well.
We can do some really cool
things, like stream logs right
from our pods.
So if we go into
our pods and click
on our voting application, you
can stream logs right here.
And we'll see that
vote that Sujit just
made coming down here
at the bottom, which
is getting blocked.
And if I want to go
back to our application
and post another
vote, we're going
to see that vote coming
in here, too, as well.
And then we can go
inside of our containers
and get access to our terminal.
So if I click on the container
for our voting application,
I'll get the terminal.
And we can do things
like ls inside
to see what's inside of our
container from the cluster
explorer.
And then we can check on the
IP addresses for our services
right here as well.
So we can look at
our voting service,
and we'll see our IP address.
And then we'll see the
location of our port.
And I want to
mention that we have
a lot of really awesome
resources available here, too.
We can see things like
secrets, persistent volumes,
and other environment
variables right
from the cluster explorer.
And this is a really
great way to increase
the visibility of what's
going on in your cluster.
And as I mentioned, while
we're showing you this in GKE,
we do have the cluster
explorer available
for any Kubernetes cluster.
So let's take a bit of a summary
and see what we've done so far.
So far, we've shown
you how easy it
is to create a cluster
right within the IDE using
our cluster creation wizard that
works for AWS, Azure, and GKE.
We've added a
deployment profile,
and then we've deployed to GKE.
We then showed you how you
can see all of your Kubernetes
resources right from the IDE
with our cluster explorer.
So let's test our app and
make sure those voting
results are coming in as
we would expect them to.
This is a little bit awkward.
Sujit, there are
no votes coming in.
You write so many
bugs in your code.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Yeah,
please don't tell my manager.
However, this is an
excellent opportunity
to showcase even more debugging
capabilities of the Cloud Code
extension.
So lets try to
troubleshoot this issue
by debugging the
application directly
against the GKE cluster.
And because the
Docker file that we
have used to deploy
the voting service has
the necessary
inspect flag already,
we don't need to
do anything else.
We can simply ensure that
the breakpoint has been set.
And we can go to
the Debug window
and click on the
Debug Voting button.
And now, we'll go back
and try to post a vote.
Yes, the breakpoint has hit.
And now, we are
[INAUDIBLE] the application
deployed in the GKE cluster.
So similarly, we can
see all the properties
on the request of
the response objects.
And we can step
through line by line.
And let's see what's going
on in vote subject here.
We expect the votes to
be stored in this format.
But it looks like the
keys and the votes
are stored as indexes
instead of the string.
So let's see what's going on
with the posted words here.
We'll step through.
The posted word is
coming out to be fine.
And now, we are iterating
what the posted words
in this for loop, and we are
[INAUDIBLE] the word subject.
Let's go one step
further and see the name.
It looks like the name is
coming up as a number here.
I think this is
because we are using
for [INAUDIBLE] loop, which
iterates over the array
indexes as opposed
to the for of loop
which iterates array values.
So let's fix it and
press [INAUDIBLE]..
I think there is a
small issue here.
Looks like it is continuously
streaming the logs.
I would like to close and open
the application once again.
Awesome.
So far, we have seen how we
can debug a single microservice
in the Kubernetes clustered.
Today, I feel a bit
brave and greedy
and would like to
show you how we
can debug multiple
microservice in the application
at the same time.
Maybe I'm pushing our
demigods a bit too much here,
but let's try this.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH D'ANGELO: Fingers
crossed for Sujit, everyone.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Yeah.
So [INAUDIBLE] explicitly
mentioned the Docker file
that we used to
deploy the front end
has the necessary
inspect flag enabled.
So we just have to create
the corresponding debug
configuration for the front
end to be able to debug it.
So I'll go to the launch.json
and add another snippet.
Let's rename this to
be debug front end,
and we'll update the local route
to the source code director
of the front-end service.
And I'll update
the port selector.
Now, let's hit the breakpoints.
So previously, I've seen the
results page of the front end.
We'll make a call to the HTP GET
endpoint of the voting service.
So we'll put a break point in
the method of the front end,
and we'll set a
breakpoint in the HTP GET
endpoint of the voting service.
So next, we'll go
to the Debug window,
click on the Debug Front End.
Now, we'll try to navigate
to the Results page.
And yes, the breakpoint
has hit on the results
method or the front end.
We can step through
and debug this.
And next, when I
press [INAUDIBLE],,
file the breakpoint has
[INAUDIBLE] GET endpoint
of the voting service.
Awesome.
Demigods are with us.
So I'll do one more
deployment of the GKE cluster.
So the code there
will be bug-free,
and Sarah will be happy.
SARAH D'ANGELO: So
this is really awesome.
I just want to point out how
easy it was for Sujit to debug
against the remote cluster.
And this is really helpful,
because in my conversations
with a lot of
developers, debugging is
one of the biggest pain points.
And so we've just
shown you how easy it
is to bug your remote cluster.
And it looks like we're going
to show you a little bit more
live debugging.
It's how you know
know it's a live demo.
As Sujit is diagnosing
this problem,
I just want to comment
on a couple of the ways
that we've shown you how you can
troubleshoot using Cloud Code.
We've shown you a lot of
the logging features that
are going to help you
diagnose your issues,
shown you that you
can debug locally
and against your remote cluster.
And then Sujit bravely
attempted to debug
multiple microservices,
which was successful.
Now, we're going to debug
this issue on the spot.
Nobody panic.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: I'll try to
deploy the GKE cluster once
again.
SARAH D'ANGELO: All
right, it's looking good.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: So far, yeah.
SARAH D'ANGELO: I get to keep
it very exciting for you guys,
but there we go.
Pretend like that didn't happen.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Let's
browse the application.
Let's post a word
and see the results.
Awesome.
It's working.
SARAH D'ANGELO: Great.
Well, I'm glad that we
finally got that working.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for your support.
We appreciate it.
And now that we have
this great audience here,
I think we could ask
them a question that
would be a little bit more fun.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Sure.
What do you want to do?
SARAH D'ANGELO: So
I know that we're
working on a lot of awesome
new features for Cloud Code,
and I'd love to get
the audience's take
on what they'd like to
see in the next release.
So I know that we're thinking
about things, like home,
customize, CRD, and GIB.
We should ask the audience what
they'd like to see support for.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: Sure.
Let's do this.
In order to do this,
let me introduce
another command called Cloud
Code continuous deploy.
Previously, we have seen the
Cloud Code deploy command
that does all the
grunt work of deploying
an application to a cluster.
And the Cloud Code
continuous deploy command
take it one step further.
What this command does
is it continuously
watches the application
directory for any changes.
And when it detects any
changes, it automatically
deploys the application
to the cluster.
This command will come
in particularly handy
when you want to rapidly
iterate on all code.
So let's see it in action.
So I"ll go the command pallet
and use Cloud Code continuous
deploy.
Let's use the default profile,
so we can iterate locally.
And now, the first
deployment has started.
And as soon as it's
complete, we can
see that the status has changed
to watching for changes.
So I'll go to the index.html
file and update the text here.
Which of these features
do you want next?
Awesome.
So as soon as I press here,
the deployment process
has started without me having
to explicitly trigger that.
So we'll see the
URL, and we can see
that the text has been
updated automatically for us.
So I'll now go ahead
and change the options
to have customize CRD.
And we'll leave the jib as-is.
And we save.
And now, the deployment
is again in progress.
I'll refresh, and now, the
options have been updated.
And I'll submit that.
And looks like we
also have to update
this in the Results page.
So I'll go back to results.html
page, to the options,
and we'll paste
this and press Save.
And once again, the
deployment process
has automatically
started for us.
Now, we'll refresh this,
and now, the Results page
has been updated as well.
So in order to stop the
continuous deployment,
we just have to click on
the Watching for Changes,
and click on Stop
Continuous Deployment.
So now, I'll do one last
deployment to the GKE cluster.
So this application will
be available for all of us
with a new questionnaire.
So also, the Cloud Code
continuous deploy command
is smart enough to only deploy
those microservices that
are being changed by the user.
So in this case, only
the front-end service
was getting redeployed
again and again.
One more thing I would like
to bring your attention
here is that as I deploy this
application back and forth
between the local and
the GKE environments,
I really didn't
have to think about
whether I'm using the
right build settings
or the right deploy
settings, or even the cluster
that I'm actually deploying
my application to.
We just had to create a
deployment profile for each
of these environments,
and the Cloud Code
is taking care of the rest.
So I'll browse this
application one last time.
See if everything is
working as we would want.
Awesome.
Now, let's go back to
the slides and take
a quick summary of what we
have done in this section.
So in this section,
we were able to remote
debug the application
deployed in the GKE cluster
and fix a bug.
And then, with the
help of the demigods,
we were able to debug multiple
microservices at the same time.
And finally, we were able
to use the Cloud Code
continuous deploy command to
rapidly iterate on our code
and update the questionnaire.
SARAH D'ANGELO: Great.
So now that we've got our voting
application up and running,
we'd love to hear your votes.
So you can go to this link right
here-- cloudcode slash demo,
or you can scan the
QR Code on the screen.
And for those of you, you might
notice that this domain doesn't
look exactly like the IP
address that's Sujit was
testing against.
I want to tell you that we
did connect our GKE cluster
to this domain before the demo.
So I promise you,
it's the same code.
And we'd really like to see
your votes because we're going
to be checking these later.
So if you don't vote,
we're just going
to get what Sujit
wants in Cloud Code.
And so while you're
all voting, I just
want to take a
little bit of time
to summarize some great Cloud
Code features that we've
talked about today.
So as you saw, we have
support for local development
with Minikube and
Docker desktop.
As I mentioned, we have support
for any Kubernetes cluster
with our cluster
explorer, and then
cluster creation with
AWS, Azure, and GKE.
We also support multiple
environments, containers,
and languages.
So there's a lot of
flexibility with this tooling,
and this is just the
beginning for Cloud Code.
And so we're really
looking forward
to continuing to expand our
support to meet your needs.
And now, the moment you've
all been waiting for--
how can you get your
hands on Cloud Code today?
So you can install and
find all the documentation
you need for Cloud Code at
cloud.google.com slash code,
or you can scan this QR
Code here on the screen.
And Cloud Code is also available
in the Visual Studio Code
marketplace.
For those of you
who use IntelliJ,
I also want to take
this time to mention
that we do have Cloud
Code for IntelliJ,
which you can find in the
[INAUDIBLE] plugin repository.
And you can find all
the documentation
at the same link on the screen.
And so we're really excited for
you to start using Cloud Code.
And as I mentioned
at the beginning,
we really do care
about your feedback,
and we take it
into consideration
when we're making
these products.
So we're logging all of
our issues on GitHub.
So you can file issues
there, and our team
will be very fast
to respond to you
and take those issues
into consideration
when we're updating Cloud Code.
So we do encourage
you to do that.
And while you're out
at the conference,
I'd like to encourage
you to come talk
to other user experience
researchers at our CPUX booth.
Because a lot of us
there, we're always
looking to talk to you about
your needs and pain points,
so we can improve our products.
So please come by and talk
to me and other researchers
at the UX booth.
And if you'd like other ways
to participate in our research
and inform our products, sign
up at userresearch.google.com.
So let's check those votes.
Wow.
All right, Helm is winning.
That's awesome.
That's really cool
to see interest
for a lot of these
different features.
And Sujit and I will bring
that back to our team
to make sure that
your voices are heard,
and we can make those
changes for Cloud Code
to meet your needs.
SUJIT KAMIREDDY: I
think we are just
scratching the surface
of helping our developers
and operators to
be more productive.
And we really hope you all
will join us in this journey.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SARAH D'ANGELO: Yes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]